this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles try
over 30 days for free a curiosity stream
calm /by a graphics and more on them in
a bit he's one of the 5 longest reigning
monarchs in the history of the world
Emperor Franz Josef ruled over first
Austria and then austria-hungary for
almost 68 years coming to the throne on
the back of a revolution aged just 18
his reign coincided with some of the
most important events in European
history it was while Franz Joseph was
Emperor that the second French Empire
rose and fell that Germany was forged by
blood and iron and most strikingly that
the events unfolded that would pave the
way for World War one yeah Franz Josef
was more than just a mere observer under
his watch Vienna became a cultural
powerhouse gifting the world Freud Klimt
Sheila and Vidkun Stein he oversaw the
creation of one of the greatest
multinational empires in history and
then lived long enough to sow the seeds
of its destruction a cipher to many a
semi mythological figure to others this
is the life of Franz Josef Europe's last
great emperor
[Music]
if you were suddenly blasted back in
time to 1830 you would find yourself in
a very different world back then there
was no such thing as Italy Germany was
39 weak states locked into an alliance
known as the German Confederation but
the biggest difference Yahtzee would be
the great round blob slap bang in the
middle of Europe the blob recovering not
just northern Italy but modern-day
Hungary Czech Republic Slovakia Slovenia
and Croatia plus parts of Poland Ukraine
and Romania known as the Austrian Empire
it was this Imperial blob that Franz
Josef was destined to rule born on
August the 18th 1830 Franz Josef could
not have come at a better time
his grandfather Emperor Francis the
first was nearing the end of his life
and the line of succession was far from
clear
while Francis had two sons the future
Emperor Ferdinand the first and Franz
Josef's own dad Francis Charles neither
of them had so far produced an heir so
when young Franz Josef emerged kicking
and screaming into the light of day the
entire Habsburg royal family gave a
collective sigh of relief yes they
finally had their future emperor great
though this was from a dynastic
perspective it was the last great from
the point of view of baby Franz Josef
from the moment he could talk the young
boy was forced to stuff his brain with
all the knowledge a ruler could possibly
need this meant mastering military
strategy European history
it meant becoming fluent in not just
German French and Latin but also
Austria's minority languages like
Hungarian Italian Czech and polish under
the watchful eye of his ambitious mother
up Duchess Sophie Franz Josef was forced
to spends nearly every waking moment
studying his progress meticulously
monitored by Austria's shadowy puppet
master met anew as a result the boy grew
up to be both obsessed with duty and
utterly lacking in imagination for his
part
Metternich considered this a win as far
as he and Archduchess Sophie could see
their precious air was shaping up to be
easy god-fearing military nan they
wanted running the Empire little did
they know that that Empire would soon be
forced to fight for its very life
[Music]
there's a game you could play when your
job is producing history videos and that
game is to see how far you can get into
the biography of any nineteenth-century
figure before you have to mention 1848
that's because 1848 is the year that
Europe exploded we've mentioned this
before it started in February when a
French government ban on banquets
lit the spark on a massive pile of
dynamite marked decades of public
resentments the flames from the
subsequent blasts quickly ignited
another box of TNT marked decades of
Austrian resentments which in turn
ignited another box marked Hungarian
resentments and another marked Italian
resentments and well so on it was a
chain reaction of revolution a series of
wildfires that combines into a European
inferno and it would nearly consume
young Franz Josef at the moments the
sparks of Frances 1848 revolution landed
on Vienna Franz Josef was a 17 year old
lad and his uncle Ferdinand the first
was on the throne the revolutionary
father too blew up on March the 13th it
would change all of that
that day students excited by the news
from Paris gathered in Vienna to demands
a new liberal Constitution in panic
Matunuck ordered cavalry to attack the
crowd which triggered a riot by 9 p.m.
that night
Austria's puppet master had resigned and
fled the country it was just the first
in a series of shocks that would bring
Austria to its knees in Hungary the
largest and most important province of
the Austrian Empire liberals forced
Ferdinand the first to grant Hungary
near total autonomy or face war in Italy
they went one step further and actually
went to war the news course such unrest
in Vienna that the Hapsburgs fled the
city well most of the imperial family
retreated to safety Franz Josef did the
opposite he went to Italy that summer
Franz Joseph personally four of Austria
turning himself into a soldier hero this
was a great contrast to Emperor
Ferdinand who quickly made himself into
a villain
that fall Ferdinand sent the Imperial
Army marching on Vienna the breathtaking
bloodshed that resulted allowed the
Hapsburgs to retake their capital but
has also left Ferdinand's reputation
ruins with Hungary now war with Austria
it was decided that the useless Emperor
he simply had to go in December 1848
Franz Josef's mum the Archduchess so
fear and an ultra reactionary known as
Prince Felix Zeus Watson Berg staged a
palace coup they forced Ferdinand to
step down replacing him with Franz Josef
for the 18 year old boy it must have
been a dizzying moment just six months
earlier he'd been a soldier fighting in
Italy now here he was ruler of an empire
that had self-destructed like a humpty
dumpty made of fissile plutonium now it
was up to him to put that Empire back
together again the arrival of Franz
Josef on the throne was initially
treated with optimism by subjects he was
a fresh-faced teenager and surely he was
gonna be more progressive than the last
guy right well those nineteenth-century
dudes they were in for a bit of a rude
awakening Franz Josef's main priority as
Emperor was to end the war with Hungary
but he didn't do this with negotiations
instead he calls in the Russians the
Russian invasion both ensured that
Hungary would stay within the Austrian
Empire and that the Hungarians would
never trust Vienna again it didn't help
that Franz Josef followed up Hungary's
defeat by having hundreds tried for
sedition driven into exile or executed
when an unemployed tailor tried to
assassinate Franz Josef shortly after it
wasn't the Emperor who ordinary
Hungarians expressed sympathy for but
his would-be assassin still the
cracktown Franz Joseph launched
coordinated from behind the scenes by
Archduchess Sofia and Prince
Schwarzenberg did have the desired
effect come the end of 18-49 the fires
of revolution across Europe had been
reduced to smoldering embers in France
the years of chaos had seen the Second
Republic rise and then fall as
Napoleon's nephew Napoleon the third
seized power in the German Confederation
the revolutionaries have tried to unite
all 39 states into a single thing called
Germany only to implode over the
question of whether Austria or Prussia
should be its leader but their efforts
had at least brought one Prussian farmer
into politics for the first time known
as Otto von Bismarck he
franz josef were destined to collide
with enough force to reshape europe
Finnell though no one could tell just
how the failed revolutions of 1848 were
going to affect the future in Austria
Franz Josef set about consolidating his
power egged on by Archduchess Sophie and
Prince Watson Burke he instituted a
reign of neo absolutism characterized by
an absolute lack of freedom of speech
brutal secret police and an invasion of
organized religion into every aspect of
citizens lives yes even at this frankly
autocratic stage the young Emperor did
find it in his heart to do some good
long after taking power he began
dismantling the anti-semitic laws that
had kept Austria's Jews confined to
ghettos and locked out of power the
destruction of these discriminatory
statutes would eventually result in a
flourishing of Jewish culture in Vienna
but his downfall Franz Josef was
thinking much about this in the early
1850s
that's because 1853 was the year that
the Emperor fell in love
in the story of Franz Joseph's life
there are three key figures the first
obviously was his mother
Archduchess Sophie who got him onto the
throne the second we already met Otto
von Bismarck would shape the Emperor's
middle years whether Franz Josef likes
it or not
the third was an unassuming Bavarian
girl of 15 called Elisabeth
but you already know her by her nickname
a girl of jaw-dropping beauty with
brown hair that came down to her ankles
was the sort of girl
words like radians are reserved for
friends Joseph first met her in 1853
when he travelled to Bavaria to propose
to her older sister Helena but the
moment the 23 year old Emperor got his
first look at Helena
metaphorically went out of the window
instead Franz Josef proposed the girl
who'd just knocked him head over heels
the marriage between Franz Josef and
ceecee was controversial for a number of
reasons back in Vienna
Archduchess sophie was enraged that her
son had ditched safe and suitable Helena
for some teenage but it was also
controversial in Bavaria for the simple
reason that the free-spirited Sisi
didn't want to marry this boring Emperor
any more than Sophie wanted her to
nevertheless Franz Josef and CC were
married on April the 24th 1854 while the
Emperor really would spend the rest of
his life devoted to his new wife it
would not be a happy marriage but if he
wanted him more about that he'll have to
check out our CC video seriously we've
got a tons of get through today so while
we're going to him more about CC we
don't really have anything like the time
we need to do her story justice in this
video however we will mention one
salient fact unlike a husband's hunger
if al-sisi was very popular in Budapest
in fact it's probably their marriage
that did more than anything else to
rehabilitate Franz Josef's image the
rest of the 1850 is passed in a blur of
blunder and babies blunders because 1855
saw Franz Josef alienage both his ally
Russia and the guys he wanted to be his
new BFFs Britain and France by dithering
over taking part in the Crimean War and
babies because well she seemed had three
of them the first Sophie sadly died
during a family visit
hungary ii gisela sadly from Franz
Joseph's perspective at least was a girl
and therefore worthless in the
ridiculous world of 19th century monix
the third though was when the emperor
got lucky on April the 21st of the 1858
CC gave birth to Crown Prince Rudolf for
the end of the arrival of the Emperor's
new heir was a cause for celebration
bah-wah Franz Josef sought baby Rudolf
as the guarantee his line would continue
he couldn't have been aware of the
darker truth in just a few short decades
Crown Prince Rudolf was going to drive
the Austrian Court into deepest despair
for all the 86 long years of his life
Franz Joseph would think of himself as a
soldier first and an emperor second so
it's ironic that the lowest point in his
reign came thanks to his appalling
military skill a year after Crown Prince
Rudolf was born the kingdom of Sardinia
approached the flamboyance French
dictator Napoleon the third and
suggested teaming up to drive Austria
out of Italy to say the plot whence a
plan is to underestimate just how
blindly if Franz Joseph blundered into
the trap in response to Sardinian
aggression he personally rode out at the
head of a vast army only to watch in
horror as the French appeared on the
horizon blowing raspberries and telling
him his mother was a hamster and his
father smelt of elderberries the
catastrophic loss of the 1859 war saw
Austria's Italian possessions almost
wiped out back home Franz Josef was
forced to call an assembly to write a
new more liberal constitution for the
Empire lest the wars outcome trigger
another 1848 gone would be the secret
police and the iron fist in their place
would be a new cuddly Austria that
didn't hate its own subjects the trouble
was that well I was easier said than
done
Franz Josef was under tremendous
pressure to give concessions to the
Hungarians but that would mean giving
concessions to the poles and the Czechs
- which would in turn mean the Austrian
right going into rebellion it seems all
that nationalistic feeling released by
1848 hadn't really gone away keeping
from tearing apart the Empire would
become a full-time job but not everyone
thought the nationalism was a dangerous
thing what Franz Josef tried to keep the
tide of 1848 from rising again up in
Prussia Otto von Bismarck was wily
enough to know that the only way to deal
with a wave is by writing it the
thirty-nine German states wanted to
unite fine it helped them do it but it
would be on his terms and that meant
insuring Austria had no part to play in
the coming Germany and so we come to the
schleswig-holstein question the details
of what this actually was aren't
important just know that they speak
Holstein were a pair of states bordering
Denmark that they had a question limb
that in 1864 Bismarck answered that
question by punching Prussia's iron fist
right through the exam paper importantly
for our story he convinced friends
Joseph to help her do it for Franz Josef
it appeared to be an easy win the joint
invasion allowed Austria to occupy
Holstein and helped Vienna cozy up to
Prussia but Bismarck was playing the
long game the one known as strengthen
Prussia at Austria's expense in January
1866 Bismarck accused Austria of misrule
in Holstein
before long the iron Chancellor had
whipped up tension so skillfully that
Franz Josef was forced to declare war
the seven weeks war was as short and as
one-sided as its name suggests devoid of
allies Franz Josef could do nothing but
watch as the highly trained Prussian
army steamroll in Austria the defeat was
so colossal that Prussia was able to
force Austria out of the United Germany
that Bismarck was now actively building
in fact the only reason was seven weeks
war didn't ends with the Austrian Empire
disintegrating is because Bismarck
didn't want to deal with a failing state
on his doorstep but the damage had been
done
Austria was now weak and Franz Joseph's
reputation was in tatters it would take
a miracle to hold everything together
after this a miracle or compromise
for the Hungarians watching Austria get
kicked around by Bismarck was the last
straw
in late 1866 they basically told Vienna
guys look we're doing this independence
thing in Vienna a panic descended some
seriously counseled going to war with
the Hungarians consequences be damned
but but Franz Josef was through being a
loser
ignoring his conservative advisors he
instead looked to his own wife see see a
longtime Hungaria file with her support
since that's of the court liberals who
surrounded her Franz Joseph managed to
get the Hawks to abandon their war plans
in place of those plans Vienna and
Budapest negotiated to compromise the
austro-hungarian compromise of 1867 was
a masterpiece of diplomatic footwork it
split the Austrian Empire into two
separate states Austria also called
Sicily Anja and Hungary also called
transition they each had their own
constitutions their own systems of
governments in their own monarchical
structures the key was that the Austrian
Emperor and the Hungarian King would
henceforth be the same person Franz
Josef join ministries would also govern
defense Foreign Affairs and Finance it
was tiptoeing to the edges of
Independence but not quite jumping from
this the austro-hungarian Empire it was
born for Franz Josef this meant not just
saving an empire from near-certain
collapse but also being crowned king of
Hungary in a lavish ceremony
Danny 20 years earlier had been a
warrior Emperor demanding the
insurrectionist Hungarians be hanged for
treason now here he was sat alongside
his Unger afar wife accepting the
elevation of Hungary to partner in his
empire to his credit Franz Joseph
accepted the world had changed that
December in 1867 he gave Austria the
constitution it had been begging for
since 1848 the new constitution laid out
citizens fundamental rights it
established Austria's first supreme
court it guaranteed the independence of
the judiciary the message was clear the
austro-hungarian Empire was a different
more liberal beast compared to the
Austrian Empire however we shouldn't kid
ourselves that everything was cool
although the new constitution placed
great emphasis on rule of our elected
representatives it maintained a veto
that Franz Josef could use on
any law and well he did a lot there was
also still the National question when
the Hungarians were elevated to equals
the Czechs were understandably all like
guys what about us that'd be nice
over on the Hungarian side things were
even more vexed while the Austria of
austria-hungary gave equal language
rights to its minorities the Hungarians
were all about stuff being Hungarian
that meant Romanian Slovenes and Serbs
all had to learn a language still the
new Empire was broadly a success as
Bismarck forged the German Empire from
blood and iron here was austria-hungary
rising instead from compromise it was
this iteration of the empire that would
give the world the grandeur of Imperial
Vienna these secession movements of
architecture and the founding of
psychoanalysis
unfortunately for Franz Josef the Golden
Age would also coincide with the darkest
period of his life and just before we
get into their darker truth and the rest
of today's video let me take a moment to
tell you about today's sponsor curiosity
stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals you can get
unlimited access starting at just $2.99
a month and for you guys the first 30
days are completely free if you sign up
a curiosity spring com /by a graphics
and use the code via graphics and look I
really can't even begin so recommends a
single video on that platform that is
well suited to this video out Franz
Joseph I mean modern European history is
a huge part of their collection and war
is something that apparently you guys
love judging by the views on our war
videos and curiosity stream they deliver
hard on the war content so really yeah
if you like this channel you're gonna
like their stuff you won't be
disappointed you can get 30 days to try
it out and see if it's for you for free
so just go to curiosity stream dot-com
forward slash biographic spot unlimited
access to the world's top documentaries
and nonfiction series and for you guys
just enter the promo code biographic s'
when prompted during the signup process
and you get 30 days for free and it
worldwide by the way so wherever you are
you can get it and let's get back to
Franz Josef
[Music]
what's remarkable with hindsight is that
we can see the storm clouds gathering
over both austria-hungary and Franz
Joseph even during the good times on the
Empire side there's the occupation of
Bosnia by austro-hungarian troops in
1878 that sparked Serbian fury there's
also the treaty franz joseph drew up
with otto von bismarck in 1879 the one
that stipulated the two states which
fights on each other side in any
european war but it was the personal
side of things that likely hit franz
joseph the hardest it started in 1878
when his mother
Archduchess sophie finally passed away
but it really took off in 1881 when
young Crown Prince Rudolf remember him
finally married Princess stéphanie of
Belgium you're probably thinking that
well that doesn't sound so tragic but
sadly it was Rudolf was an introverted
melancholy lad who didn't want to marry
this boring princess he took to having
affairs sliding deeper into unhappiness
and he cut himself off from the outside
world it was in this state that he met
Baroness Mary the 17-year old romantic
Mary was drawn to the gloomy and
melancholic side of Rudolf the two began
an affair in which they guided one
another even further into heartache and
depression finally on January the 30th
1889 the pair retreated to Rudolph's
hunting lodge there they made a suicide
pact before Rudolf shot Mary dead and
turned the gun himself and just like
that Franz Josef's only male heir was
gone the shock of the incident destroyed
the imperial family never happy in
Vienna CC now fled the city costing
herself out into the world wanting only
to be reunited with her dead son she got
her wish nine years later when an
anarchist stabbed her to death while she
was walking in Geneva with her death
Franz Joseph was suddenly alone by now a
man in his late 60s the Emperor had
reached a level of popularity with his
subjects his younger self couldn't have
dreamed of in the imperial court though
it was another story
with Rudolf gone Franz Joseph had been
forced to make his nephew Franz
Ferdinand his heir there was a problem
as Franz Ferdinand was pretty much the
most unpopular man in Austria everyone
who met him invariably wound up hating
him he was pompous stuffy awkward angry
and only happy when he was out hunting
yes there's an argument to be made that
Franz Joseph couldn't have
a better air franz joseph was a dick but
he was also a Schrute dick he could see
that the Empire's future lay in more
federalism that he could shore up by
elevating the checks on the Serbians do
joint equals with the Austrians and
Hungarians there's even a school of
thought that had friends Joseph been
assassinated instead of Sisi and Franz
Ferdinand taken his place that might
even still be austro-hungary today but
well that's not what happens for all
this bright ideas Franz Ferdinand's
would not go down in history as the man
who saved the empire rather he would go
down in the history whose death killed
millions by the dawn of the 20th century
decades of heartbreak had taken their
toll on Franz Josef the Emperor had
withdrawn from politics settling into
his role as a figurehead of the Empire
this would have been great if he
actually was a big adds but he was an
integral part of the system without
friends Joseph Simba the Empire began a
period of listless drifting known as
fortress teen while culture continued to
thrive in Vienna's the only thing of
significance to really happen before the
1910s was when Austria annexed Bosnia in
1908 kicking off a crisis that nearly
led to war but while war was avoided in
1908 it wouldn't be kept at bay for much
longer
On June the 28th 1914 the Empire's heir
Franz Ferdinand was visiting the newly
annexed province of Bosnia when a
Bosnian Serb terrorists shot him dead
the assassination sent shockwaves
through Vienna when evidence emerged
that the Serbian intelligence services
may have had a hand in the killing Franz
Joseph was forced to act at the advice
of the Hawks in his court the emperor
drew up an ultimatum to Serbia that was
effectively impossible to follow in
response Russia and France gleefully
announced that they would defend Serbian
honor from this Austrian aggression this
made Germany declare that defend
Austrian honor which made Britain and
swell this chain of events just goes on
and you know the rest on July the 28th
1914 Franz Josef signs the decree
declaring war on Serbia it would be the
last major act that it Undertaker's
Emperor the declaration effectively
started World War one not that we should
blame something so complex on poor old
Franz Joseph that
hundreds of points somebody in Serbia or
Russia or France or Germany or Britain
could have blinked and averted
catastrophe that they didn't was a
failing that went beyond one doddering
old Emperor
although friends Joseph didn't live to
see it the declaration would kill his
beloved Empire in 1918 the war drew to a
close the many nationalities
austro-hungary all made a break for it
shattering the Empire good but by this
point Franz Joseph was no longer around
on November the 21st 1916 the elderly
Emperor had died of pneumonia passing
away in the same palace in which had
been born his funeral procession on
November 30th would be the last time his
empire came together in unity even at
the time people felt like it was the end
of an era two years later but it would
all be gone from our vantage point of
the 21st century we can see that Franz
Josef was a flawed man while he
instituted reforms that turns the
autocratic Austrian Empire into a
powerhouse of culture he only did so
when his hand was forced equally while
he was a decent general we can also see
that he was hopeless when faced with a
great strategic mind like that of Otto
von Bismarck so what do we mean then
when we call him the last great emperor
well there are different ways of
defining great for son that means a
person who is exceptional someone like
Napoleon but it can also mean someone
who embodies a certain way of being
Franz Josef grew up in a world where
Emperor's were father figures who looked
after their subjects neither the tyrants
of yesterday north and mere symbols of
today by sheer dint of his long life he
became one of the very last of this type
a widely beloved figure who managed to
unite multiple nationalities under his
rule even as he still took an active
hand in empire he may have been
unimaginative obsessed with duty and too
slow to recognize the need for change
but Franz Josef was likely the last
great emperor Europe will ever see with
his death an entire age was lost forever
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that like button below and do not forget
to subscribe for brand new videos four
times a week from us here at Baia
graphics and if that's not enough for
you I've got more stuff on another one
of my channels called today I
found out it's shorter than this and
just more like interesting facts and
knowledge please go check that out if
you feel like it there is a link below
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]